[Musica]
[Applauso]
come si fa a trovare la propria strada
è una domanda talmente assillante nella
vita di ciascuno di noi che siamo pieni
di tecniche e metodi che ci dicono come
trovare una risposta
eppure alla fine ci ritroviamo sempre al
punto di partenza
il fatto secondo me che quando ci
poniamo questa domanda vogliamo una
risposta immediata
qualcuno qualcosa che ci dica guarda il
lavoro per te questo la tua strada e
quest'altra la città in cui dovresti
vivere e quest'altra ancora ma non
funziona così diciamo con l'ansia di
dover trovare una risposta immediata
perché in realtà abbiamo una paura
tremenda di quella domanda abbiamo paura
di perderci abbiamo un problema
non troviamo la nostra strada abbiamo
paura di dire mi sono perso
il fatto è che il modo per trovare la
propria strada innanzitutto e questo
perdersi e contro intuitivo ma se ci
pensate è esattamente quello che
facciamo
quando andiamo in una città nuova che
non conosciamo perdersi facilissimo ed è
bellissimo quant'è bello perdersi tra i
vicoli di genova o tra le calli di
venezia o tre quartieri di londra
coltivare la meraviglia allenare
l'intuizione vagare possiamo entrare in
negozio assurdi essere persone diverse
da quelle che siamo nella nostra città
andare a zonzo è un gioco che facciamo
senza renderci conto di quanto sia
potente ma quando lo facciamo solo
quando siamo fuori dal nostro ambiente
lo fate mai nella vostra città
probabilmente no perché la conoscete
come le vostre tasche
e mica avrete bisogno di scoprirla no e
poi avete troppe cose da fare non avete
tempo
ecco il problema ecco la ragione per cui
delle cose che ci piacevano tantissimo a
un certo punto ci vengono a noia cose
persone città lavori non perché abbiano
perso potere d'attrazione
ma perché noi abbiamo smesso di giocare
sei disposto ad andare a zonzo a vagare
in una città che non conosci
ma non in quella che conosci già eppure
il genius loci si attiva solo quando sei
risposto a perderti tutto questo a che
fare con le idee con le cose che
presumiamo di sapere e di saper fare
perché dopo un po nella nostra vita
diventa tutto automatico meccanico tutto
smette di stupirci i e quindi smettiamo
di innovare di giocare di sperimentare
ecco il più grande ostacolo
all'innovazione e alla creatività
consiste proprio nell incapacità di
guardare con occhi nuovi
ciò che ordinario ciò che già pensiamo
di conoscere
sì ma come si fa c'è una storia che mi
piace raccontare che riguarda due
scrittori francesi lo bello e mi passano
ma passa un fin da piccolissimo voleva
fare lo scrittore e flaubert si occupò
lungo della sua fioritura macchiò che
passargli il proprio stile più che
dargli una tecnica quello che a flumeri
interessava era passare mo passanti
l'importanza del coltivare l'attenzione
una volta in una lettera mutuando
chateaubriand gli scrisse il talento è
una lunga pazienza
ora voi immaginate un ragazzino come ma
passa anche vuole fare lo scrittore che
non ha una grande pazienza a sentirsi
dire queste cose
ebbene uno degli esercizi uno degli
esercizi più importanti che flaubert
divide da fare consisteva nel mettersi
davanti un albero per ore e far finta di
non sapere che cosa fosse
non c'erano radici tronco foglie non
doveva sapere non doveva immaginare di
averne mai visto uno prima di allora e
quindi immaginate questo ragazzino con
poca pazienza che probabilmente da
flaubert voleva solo un endorsement
essere introdotto a personaggi del tempo
come ivan turgenev isola dover stare
davanti a un albero per ore e facendo
finta di non sapere di che cosa si
trattasse perché flaubert poi l'avrebbe
introdotto nella comunità letteraria ma
solo dopo quella apprendistato
ebbene ovviamente l'esercizio di
flaubert non riguarda solo la scrittura
ma può essere fondamentale per qualunque
professione tu abbia intenzione di fare
o stia già facendo e l'approccio
essenziale
per disfarsi dei si fa così e aprirsi al
nuovo
del resto flaubert diceva che dobbiamo
guardare ciò che vogliamo esprimere
tanto a lungo e con tanta attenzione da
scoprire un aspetto che non sia mai
stato visto da nessun altro prima d'ora
perché in tutto c'è qualcosa di
inesplorato
solo che noi come esseri umani siamo
abituati a servirci dei nostri occhi
sono con il ricordo di quanto è stato
detto visto su quella cosa prima di noi
eppure la cosa più insignificante
contiene un po di ignoto troviamolo per
descrivere un fuoco che divampa e un
albero in una pianura
dovremmo restare di fronte a quel fuoco
e a quell'albero finché non assomiglino
per noi più a nessun altro fuoco e
nessun altro albero è così che si
diventa originali cosa intendeva dire
flaubert
innanzitutto che si tratta di guardare
ciò che vogliamo esprimere tanto a lungo
e con tanta attenzione e ma per farlo ci
vuole tempo per innovare
ci vuole tempo per scoprire davvero
qualcosa bisogna perderci si dentro per
tantissimo tempo e lo sappiamo oggi
questo tempo è raro e sempre più raro
perché viviamo nella società della
performance dobbiamo sbrigarci dobbiamo
sempre fare in fretta
ora quante volte al giorno diciamo e ci
giustifichiamo dicendo non ho tempo
oggi la sola idea di fare quello che
facevamo passato ci infastidisce ma il
punto che quella apprendistato non
dovremmo farlo una volta sola ma
dovremmo rinnovarlo ogni volta e forse
soprattutto se possediamo già i ferri
del mestiere flaubert dice che in tutto
c'è qualcosa di inesplorato e che anche
la cosa più insignificante contiene un
po di noto solo che noi non ci diamo il
tempo per trovarlo e così finisce che
tutto nella vita ci sembra uguale
prevedibile ci annoia smette di stupirci
e di nuovo il problema non è nelle cose
bene il nostro sguardo
e allora come si diventa originali per
firmware restando di fronte al fuoco che
divampa e all'alberone una pianura
finché non assomigliano più per noi a
nessun altro fuoco
un altro albero finché non cinque minuti
non di sfuggita ma per tutto il tempo
che ci vuole
noi siamo convinti di non averlo questo
tempo
ma c'è un'altra ragione abbiamo paura di
trovarci di fronte all'albero sbagliato
al fuoco sbagliato e se non fosse quello
giusto e se stessi perdendo nelle
occasioni
ecco il punto è che l'albero giusto non
c'è è solo un'occasione perché tu possa
esprimere la tua originalità e solo uno
spazio che tu ti apri quello spazio che
si crea se riesci a fermarti invece
quello che facciamo esattamente il
contrario perché abbiamo fretta perché
non possiamo perdere occasioni
interessanti perché dobbiamo sbrigarci
non possiamo avere tentennamenti
non possiamo mai cambiare strada questo
però ci condanna a vivere sulla
superficie delle cose a non andare in
profondità a non scoprire davvero come
esprimere tutta la nostra essenza allora
è chiaro che ci sentiamo sempre senza
idee perché le idee avrebbero pure
voglia di venire da noi
solo che non trovano spazio ci avete
pensato al fatto che diciamo mi è venuta
un'idea perché l'immagine che abbiamo è
che l'idea sia qualcosa che si trova in
un altrove
e chi ci viene a trovare solo che se ci
viene a trovare e non trova spazio
perché noi siamo distratti perché
pensavo di non avere tempo e non si può
raggiungere non riusciamo intercettarla
come si fa a farsi venire una buona idea
cambiando percorso evitando i tragitti
consueti e invece noi continuiamo
alimentare la paura che uscendo dal
tragitto rigidissimo che ci siamo
costruiti potremmo perderci
invece bisogna cercare di perdersi non
bisogna avere paura bisogna rischiare di
perdersi e rischiare di annoiarsi quanto
spazio c'è per la noia nella vostra vita
walter bene e mi diceva che la noia è un
uccello incantato che cova luogo
dell'esperienza perché la noia è un
ingrediente fondamentale del processo
creativo
perché quello che crea spazio
fai in modo che le idee possano essere
intercettati eppure ogni volta che
abbiamo un momento di noia
cerchiamo subito di riempirlo e lo
riempiamo spesso con un intrattenimento
superficiale invece la noia ci aiuta a
fare spazio ad allargare il nostro la
nostra essenza ad allargare la nostra
mente è essenziale al cervello
soprattutto se quello che desideriamo e
farci venire buone idee
tutto quello di cui sto parlando è un
modo di pensare divergente due millenni
e mezzo più o meno che viene considerato
quella cosa con la quale senza la quale
si rimane tale e quale qualcosa di
totalmente slegato dalla vita reale dal
mondo concreto e che invece secondo me è
essenziale per vivere la propria vita
per fare innovazione e per trasformarsi
ed è la filosofia il pensiero filosofico
e straordinariamente attuale perché ci
permette di vedere quali sono i vostri
pregiudizi e gli ostacoli che ci
impediscono di creare disegnare il
nostro percorso
si tratta di quella che chiamo fioritura
personale che è qualcosa che aiuta a
entrare dentro i problemi a mettere in
connessione fatti e discipline che
sembrano lontanissimi ea creare dei
ponti è un grande strumento di
orientamento ma anche di disorientamento
perché ti spinge a farti davvero le
domande a cercare soluzioni allenando il
pensiero divergente coltivando
l'impressione perché come se avessi la
possibilità di muoverti tra i pensieri
in un modo antico ma sempre nuovo e per
farlo basta discorsi alla meraviglia al
gioco e alla riflessione perché la
filosofia ti spinge a vedere te stesso
non come un treno che deve andare più
veloce possibile su un binario dritto ma
come una persona che può disegnare il
proprio labirinto e mentre lo disegna
può scoprire un sacco di tesori la
filosofia come fiorito la personale
parla di questo del fatto che non sei un
treno sul binario dritto ma sei un
pellegrino che non sei una mappa a sei
un territorio che non vi tantissime cose
che noi
segni di montagne di baie di vascelli di
astri gli strumenti invece quello che ci
dicono che siamo una cosa sola
ma questo è un grande e pregiudizio un
grandissimo fraintendimento
il pensiero filosofico aiuta a mettere
in circolo la meraviglia sentire la
luccicanza delle cose e accade anche con
l'immagine che abbiamo di noi perché man
mano che diventiamo adulti che cresciamo
ci convinciamo di essere una cosa sola e
ci convinciamo di conoscerci io sono
fatta così
chiedetemi di fare questo ma non
chiedetemi di fare quest'altro a me
piace questo ma non mi piace
assolutamente quest'altro ecco la
soggettività umana però non funziona
così perché noi siamo pieni di desideri
di orientamenti di inclinazioni che
cambiano nella vita
cambiamo gusti cambiamo tutto ma
facciamo fatica ad assecondare questi
cambiamenti che ci aiuterebbero a creare
a disegnare il nostro labirinto perché
dobbiamo alimentare l'immagine fissa che
abbiamo di noi
il tragitto sempre uguale che abbiamo
fatto e che ci fa stare bene
apparentemente perché non ci mette paura
ecco non siamo noi quel tragitto perché
noi non siamo un punto su una mappa di
una città noi siamo tutta una città e se
smettiamo di perderci smettiamo anche di
trovarci se ci convinciamo di essere un
piccolo punto in una mappa gigantesca
finiamo quello smettere di viaggiare
dentro di noi
ecco disegnare il proprio percorso il
proprio labirinto aiuta a prestare più
attenzione a ogni cosa a coltivare la
meraviglia il gioco rendersi conto di
ciò che ancora non si sa anche su se
stessi soprattutto su ciò che si presume
di sapere sulla città in cui si vive
e sulla città che si è in un certo senso
si tratta di prendersi del tempo per
quello che per noi ha un senso
si tratta di essere disposti a restare
davanti al fuoco che divampa davanti
all'albero in una pianura
finché non assomigliano più per noi
a nessun altro fuoco ea nessun altro
albero finché perché questo ci aiuta a
scoprire la nostra originalità a
esprimere la nostra essenza
ecco tutto questo oggi possiamo farlo
nello spazio fisico ma possiamo farlo
anche nel più grande spazio che abbiamo
mai avuto come esseri umani il più
grande spazio pubblico lo spazio
pubblico digitale
anche qui possiamo farci venire delle
idee anche qui possiamo attivare il
genius loci e quello che cerco di fare
con tron rendendo la filosofia
accessibile a tutte le persone che hanno
voglia di farsi delle domande su di sé e
sul mondo tron è un progetto filosofico
che ho creato con mio marito andrea con
la medici ed è un laboratorio di
riflessioni e contaminazioni
ari berson diceva che la filosofia non è
la costruzione la capacità di costruire
i sistemi ma la risoluzione presa una
volta e per tutte di guardare
ingenuamente in sé è intorno a sé
ingenuamente quando viaggiamo
recuperiamo questa dimensione di
ingenuità perché non abbiamo paura di
sentirsi stupidi
ecco si tratta di questo si tratta di
non valutare più l'ingenuità la
sincerità la veracità come qualcosa di
negativo e smettere di avere questa
paura
lo stesso accade per esempio quando ci
innamoriamo fare filosofia significa
coltivare queste ingenuità e renderla
una pratica di vita non accettare i
binari dritti e imparare a disegnare il
proprio labirinto
e allora come si fa a trovare la propria
strada
la strada si trova se si ha il coraggio
di imparare a perdersi se si è disposti
a rimanere davanti all'albero e al fuoco
senza la paura di annoiarsi perché la
noia non è un nemico ma è essenziale
alla creatività
ecco trovare la propria strada non
significa in fondo avere
risposta definitiva sul lavoro che
dovremmo fare o sulla città in cui
dovremmo vivere significa piuttosto
imparare a giocare con il mondo e con la
propria vita liberarsi dai
condizionamenti esprimere la propria
essenza è così come diceva flaubert che
si diventa originali
[Applauso]